[Applause]
snoop dogg and dr dre reunited at super
bowl 56.
[Applause]
the rappers performed two of their most
famous hits the next episode in
california love
[Music]
[Applause]
snoop and dre kicked off the nfl
star-studded halftime show making their
way across a series of trailers each one
representing different sides of los
angeles mary j blige eminem kendrick
lamar and 50 cent rounded out the
impressive ensemble how excited are you
for the halftime show super excited man
snoop is here man it's going down before
heading into the game wiz khalifa shared
his excitement with e.t also what does
it mean to see that diversity on this
halftime show stage you haven't seen
before i know right it's been a long
time coming man it should have i mean
you know snoop is a household name the
whole west coast just in general the
work that all of them catch them put in
so it's big man i'm happy busta rhymes
even said he got emotional watching the
performance what does it mean to see
this group of folks break through on
this stage you know
damn well
what this moment means not just for our
culture
obviously primarily what it means for
our culture is everything
everything
but
just on an intergalactic level
beyond earth i was fortunate enough to
be able to come and witness with one of
the rehearsals emotional for me for
tears
proud and tears of joy though this
moment it's gonna force the hands of
every other genre you ain't got no
choice i don't care what type of music
you make
you don't have a choice from this night
moving forward i mean these are the
avengers of music all together in one
halftime show these are superstars
jessie collins one of the halftime
show's producers gave e.t all the
behind-the-scenes details
you know this is one of the fastest
first halfs in nfl history and so
we had to make sure that there was
plenty of production value lights in the
stadium huge set
and then just monster hits monster
artists i think we proved tonight that
hip-hop
is part of the american dna it is part
of our culture forever just like rock
and roll country all the rest of it
hip-hop is right there and it's never
going away and it is americana period
leading up to sunday schnoop and dre
explained what makes this an important
moment super bowl is the biggest
sporting event in the world and hip-hop
is the biggest form of music in the
world yup and for us to be able to have
the opportunity to bring the two worlds
together we got the queen of r b yep we
got the king of hip-hop yep we got
just his all of his
you know proteges in the place this is
what it's about i'm not trying to be um
egotistical or anything like that but
who else could do this show here in l.a
um no one no that's a fact who else
could perform the halftime show other
than these amazing artists that that we
put together for this um for this thing
[Music]
you